the choreography that you were talking
about which is where you find a way to
block the light from the star and not
block the light from the planet and then
you can actually see the planet so all
these methods up to now you're not
actually seeing the planet you're seeing
the planets shadow or you're seeing the
planets gravity but but what we're
looking for is to build telescopes where
you're blocking the light from the star
which is a lot harder than it sounds
could be like taking this and putting it
up there well if it were that simple it
wouldn't be that hard so if it were if
it were enough to just put a little dot
where the star is we could do that the
problem is that when when you it would
be a very small dot because the star is
very far away so this star is really
really tiny it's almost essentially a
point the problem is that when you have
dots that small the light doesn't behave
the way you expect you get diffraction
effects where the light bleeds around
the edge of the dot correct and if you
make the dot big enough to not have that
happen now you're blocking the planet so
what you have to do is get clever and
and what you do is you if you if you
insist on using a dot what you do is you
kind of see rate the edge of the dot you
give the edge of a dot a texture which
if it's designed just right will
actually cause that diffraction to
cancel out what would the touch should
be
um there's uh well there's different
there's different approaches sometimes
it's a sort of a sometimes it's sort of
a serration like I said at night
sometimes it's a very complicated shape
where the light actually comes through
the content complicated shape
now there's two ways to block the light
one is to have a telescope where the
light gets focused inside the telescope
and then you put a little dot where the
focus is and that's called a that's
called a coronagraph I'm actually
involved in this star shade as the other
so I'll get to that okay so I'm actually
involved in some of the design for
next-generation coronagraphs it's a long
time these days that's very exciting yes
and then but that's still really hard to
do is you're gonna be the light in the
telescope and blocking the light in this
old school that's really hard to do yeah
because you're working with very very
tiny dot so they have to be just right
it's really amazing yeah so some folks
came up with this other absolutely crazy
sounding idea where what they do is
instead of a dot inside the telescope
you have your telescope over here and
then you have a shade that's way over
there and you line them up so the shade
blocks the light of the star but
but to but but to have the shade block
just a light of the star and not the
light of the planet these things have to
be hundreds of thousands of kilometers
apart really far apart which means
you've gotta have them lined up really
perfectly and keep them lined up and
then say you want to look over there you
got to find a way to both of them that's
crazy
so it's crazy sounding but it has
tremendous that if you can do it it's
got tremendous advantages and so both
ways in the composition of a planet well
so the point of both of these methods is
to see the planet take pictures of the
planet in color yeah and if you can
detect the colors of the planet then you
can measure its atmosphere yeah and then
you could look for the kinds of
chemicals like for example oxygen is
very suggestive of life it's not
completely definitive but it's very
suggestive that there's active life if
you can see oxygen in the atmosphere
but but the question is is the
coronagraph the best way to do it or is
a star shade the best way to do these
days NASA is pushing hard on both of
them yeah yeah to figure it out yeah